I whipped all my stuff behind my laptop
my phone everything this guy's dangerous
you want to get your business in terms
of my hands fire it's a weed I'm an
optimist
good morning time to start an up day
forget who's speaking today I think Zoey
and Gweneth or speaking in the morning
and Daymond John and Herjavec in the
afternoon I'm supposed to do a thing
with Stephen a meeting at noon hang out
later on the day and otherwise got to
keep doing some more videos for the
channel and whatever else one comes up
today super excited I'm gonna find the
bus head off to the convention center
and start day to its I'm super early
I've got another power to happen so the
keynote starts could he use em for some
sleep time but I'm going to try to find
the spot you can see here it's like
totally dead only a couple people and
their pretty ram later today then you
try to find a spot to
plug in and work on some YouTube videos
I've got a bunch of things that I
interview to help pick the top 10s look
at the ants press oohs and do some
filming later on today so you guys have
something to watch got to find a spot to
sit down and get to work
sandy here wants to do a selfie with
Santiago who's yellow
chief marketing officer this guy is
always up for getting my picture taken
under this beautiful face
Wow
there's the backstage is to find high
importance you wanna can your business
pictures of quite an aspiring so wait so
I got my picture with Gwyneth ins early
the guys who am I ticket in at the end
of the session like the speech hasn't
even finished and they're jumping off
and running out say okay we got to go so
I just jump over the chair I whipped all
my stuff behind my laptop my phone
everything so I got to go back and pick
it up and hopefully it's still there as
you can see the place is totally empty
now so next time I'll be a little more
prepared to just exit on a dime i just
brought my video camera with me and
that's it so I'm gonna go see if I can
pick up my stuff fingers crossed here we
go and there it is there's my macbook
air and my bag in my case we are good so
I've got about an hour until my meeting
read with Stephen again knocking social
media so I don't know might check out
some sessions
in the building here don't have quite
enough time to film videos
no explore see what I find it's the
world-famous Barry about that there is
are you igniting your passion here i'd
say 2016 I am only because Evan
Carmichael's here from Toronto Canada
what are you speaking today yeah a
couple times what are you doing what's
the session one stupid mistakes an
entrepreneur's make and the other one is
keep your friends close your enemies
closer what's the number one stupid
mistake on Turner's make it don't keep
track of their cash flow I love you
going to business with people they don't
know I love it much love there much love
boom all right it's lunchtime Italian
station is sausage calzone or spinach
mushroom calzone this is the garden
fresh station chicken and avocado wrap
american stations mac and cheese garlic
bread look i'm going to go with the
italian station get some sausage calzone
it's not too spicy
let's get it on I wonder if they're
ready
ok so it's 1140 and the food is still
not ready they said it's gonna be ready
at eleven fifteen and we had a sitting
waiting I have to get to an event
mistype in social media hangout
something at 12 so I've gotta head over
there I've got some bars between just in
case we need to be some food there
fingers crossed I'm gonna get angry
let's find my way
alright i'm here at the sage press
center where we're supposed to meet
Steven I don't know where I'm going
we'll go inside we got some brownies
here to eat some nuts some chips and
brown
and code this will be like here with
seven Kelly pressroom got to do we're
meeting up to pack mates out we do
webcam where I think we should do at the
center who I want to do out there would
maybe get a few people by I like so on
it entreprise that works
alright alright every day I'll film it
so do it wherever it is going rock star
ever Carmichael now in Chicago just
across the lake but North America is
waking up to the parasocial we love it
they already love you
I love you guys out that we love you
guys we're having a lot of fun in
chicago absolutely it's just crazy we
just have when it's all true to ditch
them now amazing actually when it's just
so feels great what about the veterans
yeah I've Brian Stann yeah so much
common said you're they are
testing to see you later yep I haven't
reported a video for a bit have a great
time in the press room the sage guys had
a lot of nice things say about me which
is always flattering right now I'm
heading off to the main room again
Daymond John and Robert Herjavec are
going to be speaking so I'm going to
film them and see what they have to say
and hopefully meet them backstage for a
meet-and-greet
the day continues I'm excited Sarah
Hauer yell for eternity nice to meet you
too tell them well I'm sharron rush was
staged and I do the sponsorship program
and so excited to be here gotta see
rounded and Dana backstage she's always
photobombing the big photo bomber change
it came to Twitter hanging the photo
bomber we snuck in and not only that we
got the like extra VIP passes from
Stephen Kelly for tonight so now i have
to i wasn't going to go god I guess guy
was going to guilt me into going tonight
to see the killers like I got to prepare
tomorrow a presentation she even
summoned by the CEO and then and then he
kind of called me out in front of
Stephen Kelly and so now I have to go
Stephen Kelly personally asked me and
gave me like the bonus VIP think so
Santiago gave us a VIP and then Stephen
gave us like the extra VIP the Stephen
Kelly VIP so now now I have to go so I
gotta do might hang out with him and
then go home and practice a presentation
for tomorrow so that I'm good to go for
it was gonna be good it's all gonna be
don't keep me up late get me drunk I got
it was going to kill her presentation
tomorrow this guy's dangerous
gonna grab a coffee get some caffeine
here look who it is nobody got time for
that
they're all empty look over here there's
more of it here it's hard to get coffee
in this place fueled by coffee and
photobombing hashtag oh we have a pass
for you you didn't get the thing you can
Santiago gave us VIP passes tonight and
then and then when we got inside Stephen
gave us like the Cougar VIP passes no I
said we'll give our VIP passes to
Rebecca oh all right next up I'm doing a
hangout with Stephen Kelly want to hang
out this time you want to do on scene we
wanted to be outside with everything you
can see it but the Wi-Fi connection here
isn't strong enough to be able to do a
consistent half hour stream so we booked
off a room that has a hard cable and i'm
going to set up and then get ready to
talk with you guys live let's give it a
go we're filming here and stephen wanted
to show everybody the the floor I so I'm
standing on a chair what the show people
up there
that's Melissa hey everybody melissa is
in charge of all the content for sage
what's what's coming up with some new
content that we can get excited for well
I think what Evans is steven is amazing
if you missed it
on his channel it was
and
you know the content from Summit this
year was the best ever and next year is
going to be even better than that if you
miss anything from summit and you
couldn't get here to Chicago go to save
some it's live Google it'll be the first
thing you stayed register you can see
all the systems on demand Richard
Branson
you have to register but it's free just
watch me register that he can get it and
see
cool we're gonna get head back to the
hotel I'm going to practice my speech
for tomorrow and then go watch the
killers tonight the traffic was crazy
for some reason I don't know what's
going on some people are saying Michelle
Obama is here just basically sat down
and was moving so bunch of us got off
the bus instead of walking well I
actually don't really know how far we're
him and I don't have a map but i'm
hoping that i find it at least i'm
making progress and not just a ton of us
doing nothing I made it tired but I made
it I think I still be if it cleared up
but then I got busy again with downtown
traffic
anyway what time is it don't know
shower time what you have to wash and if
we get up shirts I always bring one
extra pair of shirts just in case but I
used it last night because I had to go
out and I need another one tonight that
I gotta go up I used to spending all
this time out
so I gotta hand wash a shirt I've it
ready for tomorrow apply it to see my
wife I'm in trouble it's already 624 my
speech is supposed to be an hour so I
have less than I would prepare change
shower wash my shirt eat I meet them in
the lobby at seven thirty go alright so
i found a solution did not have to do
any laundry because i have my sage
summit shirt that Stephen gave me or
Stevens daughter gave me during our
presentation so it's long sleeve I
rolled it up but in case it gets chilly
tonight I love it's indoor/outdoor I'll
have something that I can wear so I'd
save some time we're a presentation once
I'm on the fence whether i should sleep
in tomorrow and practice solidly or wake
up early and go watch I think it's
ashton kutcher and the fan of
kickstarter in the morning we'll see i
guess it's depend on how tired i am
coming home what time to get back so i'm
going super light no backpack no tripod
just the camera the camera bag gonna go
eat some food there's a freshie
downstairs and then i have to me
everybody in the lobby killers so i got
options soup and wrap bowl soup or
burritos if you know what here she'd
want the soup or the soup and raf i'm
feeling either the burritos or balls one
with a pen goa bowl that's usually spicy
teriyaki sauce and then there's
smoothies look interesting so then I
have a banana nut crunch
it's good we'll see then it was decent
fan of the shapes might come back
another one later on the street now we
are about to get on the bus the head off
to see the killers in concert waiting
for some friends I'm going to look at
this traffic so their lettuce what is
like that [ __ ] popular just walking
ashikaga I had a good nap no homo power
not somebody somebody pushed me to wake
up but it always but like get off the
bus now I'm going to get a ticket for
stopping here I'm serious get out the
bus I don't know how far we're going
we're following the crowds this is where
we're going this is where we're going so
that stadium is not where we're going
there's a huge soccer game happen there
that all these people going to and we've
got another 12 minute walk to get to our
place because we go tues Rebecca hooked
us up with google chopped up on the
freeway hook this up yeah we got dropped
off the middle of a highway he said go
get off i'm getting a ticket go without
tell us where we're going like it's
somewhere over there figure it out we're
trying to find the killer okay this is
where we actually are supposed to be
very exciting celebration
you
alright so the killers are rocking it
back there it's about 10-20 I'm going to
see if I can duck out a little early
catch a bus back and practice what is
this you're gonna rain Haley gonna
render is it win today
I'm an optimist hope it doesn't rain you
got to get back anyway yeah watching
them perform and either thing makes me
want to deliver an amazing performance
tomorrow so going home see if I can
catch a bus practice practice practice
do some packing because I'm not coming
back to the hotel after I leave tomorrow
I'm going right to my session and then
meeting and greeting and then one of my
subscribers picking me up taking to the
airport get home see Nina and that's it
here we go